[MUSIC PLAYING]
TARQUIN CLARK: Finding a
job, no matter your industry,
can be tough.
And if you're hiring,
getting your job in front
of the right candidate can be
both challenging and expensive.
Part of the challenge is
that there is no standard
for writing job postings.
As companies, we often
use internal language
to describe job titles that
may not be obvious to seekers.
This issue is
compounded by the fact
that most off-the-shelf search
technology is keyword-based,
focusing on the two to
three generic words that
often make up job titles.
While keyword search is
effective at matching keywords
to content, it typically
fails to return good results
when used for job search.
Cloud Job Discovery
offers access
to Google's proven search and
machine learning capabilities
through a plug-and-play
Cloud service,
improving job
discoverability, job seeker
experience, and conversion.
It's packed with functionality,
such as seniority alignment,
job-related synonym
and acronym detection,
to improve the job
seeker experience.
And we're constantly
talking to job seekers
to find innovative ways to
help them discover new jobs,
like preferred commute
time and mode of transit.
So how does it work?
Let's take a look at a job site
powered by Cloud Job Discovery.
This could be a job board,
career site, applicant tracking
system, or any
other jobs property.
The job content on
the site is first
inserted into a private tenant
on the Google Cloud Platform.
Cloud Job Discovery
then goes to work,
parsing, classifying,
and mapping the content
to pre-trained data models,
which codify our knowledge
and understanding of
occupations, skills, education,
and more.
Here's a visual representation
of our title data
model, which contains over
254,000 normalized titles, each
belonging to one of 30
top-level categories.
This knowledge enables us to
return not just the correct
role for each job seeker, but
also similar roles nearby.
When job seekers
search on the site,
we apply machine learning
to truly understand
the intent of the query,
and then retrieve, rank,
and return highly
relevant results that
continue to improve over time.
Hiring companies with career
sites powered by Cloud Job
Discovery, such as
Johnson & Johnson,
have seen remarkable
increases in career site
engagement and
candidate conversion,
especially on
hard-to-fill roles.
Job boards and applicant
tracking systems
using Cloud Job Discovery,
such as CareerBuilder,
are also seeing
increased engagement,
and are benefiting
from their product
and engineering teams' ability
to focus on tasks higher
in the tech stack.
Matching qualified
candidates with the right job
doesn't have to be so hard.
Let Google power your job
site with machine learning
and improve the discoverability
of jobs on your property.
Learn more at cloud.google.com.